sa note 'aaa' casse la conversion
écologique du pape françois dans une
encyclique très attendu sur
l'environnement le pam appelle les
gouvernements à l'action pour sauver la
planète
pour lui il est clair que c'est l'homme
qui est le principal responsable du
réchauffement climatique
il balaie ainsi l'opinion des
climato-sceptiques pour lesquelles ce
réchauffement a surtout des causes
naturelles et il exhorte les pays riches
les nantis à aider les plus pauvres à
réaliser la transition énergétique bref
c'est un texte très politique qui mérite
vraiment qu'on fasse appel la lumière de
mon collègue alain crevier de l'émission
second regard alain c'est vraiment plus
qu'une encyclique c'est presqu'un
appelle à une révolution verte
vous avez raison vous mettez le doigt
dessus parce qu une encyclique on
imagine que c'est une réflexion du pape
ou encore tout simplement un
enseignement du pape
en lisant ce texte de 192 pages dans
lequel il ya six chapitres il y en a
qu'un seul dédié à la bible alors qu'en
lisant ce texte là on a clairement
l'impression que françois est devenu en
quelque sorte le porte parole des
experts des environnementalistes des
scientifiques des grandes personnes
qu'il a rencontrées au fil des mois et
des gens en fait une masse de gens qui
ont envie de dire c'est assez
j'irai plus loin que ça céline je dirais
que j'ai eu le sentiment que c'était pas
tellement une encyclique ce que je
venais de lire mais que ça ressemblait
davantage à un manifeste et même
allons-y ça ressemble à un appel au
combat pour rien rien moins que ça bon
il le fait avec toute son autorité
morale quel impact ça peut vraiment
avoir il ya déjà un impact
depuis quelques jours il ya déjà aux
états unis vous saviez pas mal de gens
aux états unis qui sont des
climato-sceptiques et vous avez
maintenant des gens qui sont apolitiques
qui ont réagi de façon assez véhémente
d'ailleurs je pense à rick santorum qui
voudrait bien se présenter auprès aux
élections présidentielles et qui disait
dans le fond monsieur le pape vous savez
l'église votre église a fait souvent des
erreurs avec la science alors peut-être
que ce serait une bonne idée de laisser
ces choses-là aux scientifiques
jeb bush qui a dit moi je ne prendrai
pas mais politique économique de mon
évêque de mon cardinal et pas plus de
mon pape
et puis vous en avez un autre sénateur
qui a dit peut-être que le pacte devrait
se mêler tout simplement de ses affaires
or si on me demande si le franc soit
avoir un impact dans ce débat la réponse
est oui il ya mis le feu aux poudres
est-ce que c'est pas un peu inhabituel
pour un pape d'être aussi politique
parce qu'on sait que ça arrive là
quelques mois de la grande conférence de
paris sur le climat vous avez raison
vous savez jean paul ii était un homme
moi je pense que je peux le dit être un
homme vraiment très politique c'était
une époque très particulière la guerre
fois l'union soviétique la pologne et il
a joué un rôle important dans tout ça
benoît c'est au contraire c'est un homme
effacé le théologien un homme de la
réflexion et vous avez maintenant
françois qui est véritablement un cas
singulier vous savez ya deux ans vous et
moi on était à rome pour le conclave et
on se demandait à voix haute d'ailleurs
on se disait est ce que le fait que
cette âme là viennent d'argentine d'un
pays du sud un pays du tiers-monde mais
ce pays en développement du sud
est ce que ça va changer quelque chose
vous avez la réponse maintenant c'est
très clair les 192 pages de cette
encyclique respire le sud on a
l'impression que les préoccupations de
ceux qui ont souvent été bafoués ou
ignorés sont présentement ça dans sa
réflexion
c'est tout au long de ce de cette
encyclique qu'on a cette chose là alors
je vous dirais que oui puis à partir de
maintenant vous allez voir le ski vont
pas ce qui va prendre le relais ce sont
les paroisses des milliers de paroisses
comprendre le relais de françois dans ce
discours là vous allez avoir après ça
françois qui ira à washington à la
maison blanche à l'onu au congrès et
puis ensuite en décembre la grande la
grande conférence de parieurs tout ça
s'inscrit dans un mouvement auquel
françois thomas participer on va
continuer de suivre le pas françois avec
vous parce que c'est assez intéressant
ce qui se passe merci beaucoup
ça me fait plaisir